l'échelle est ce que vous vous est déjà
pris pour une célébrité avec quelle
célébrité on vous a déjà confondu ou
bien de quelle vraie célébrité pas parce
que vous êtes des célébrités mais
j'aurai la danse avec les stars damon a
compris quelle célébrité vous est le
sosie vous par exemple christophe
rocancourt
si c'est vrai cela invite au reste on
dit on est content de vous avoir
christophe francon cassé pour nous
l'addition dit non je dis rien savard et
célébrera chose j'ai fini j'ai arrêté je
[Rires]
suis top en temps pour l histoire avec
elle et je les rencontre mallory et
sympathique bonjour il est sympa valérie
bénaïm chimène badi
ouais non julia robert non robert plus
tôt non non on dit souvent que géraldine
nakache pour être ma fille oui c'est
vrai
hirawi ah oui à quelque chose ah ouais
ouais ouais ouais ben yahia les cheveux
secs et mes cheveux mouillés armes et
ses normes et ses fous c'est vrai qu'il
ya quelque chose
jean-michel vers moi le regretté matthew
perry a défait à manon mes matches
étaient mieux
dans l'attenté ribéry c'est luke perry
[Rires]
alors dans cette news est ce que ce
n'est pas lui qui fait lui que tout
court ce que là franchement je vois pas
bah écoute si c'est le regretté en tous
cas cellule parce que lui ne les lit les
livres il est à regretter c'est l'autre
nom du coup sûr notre photo un sur sa
droite soda nilan de look maison dylan
devait d alice mais hier c'était le plus
beau gosse apple de kelly à moi on m'a
dit meghan mccain alors elle est pas
très connue en flapi de des frites et
mieux les bourses on n'a pas mangé de
frites non mais ça m'a dit c'est vrai
plus non mais ils viennent des frites
mado mieux non elles viennent de chez
mccain
oui à bouger j'ai regardé ça parce que
cet été j'ai fait beaucoup de recherches
les questions sur les frites et bien mes
frites mccain
elles sont faites au mac do et les
nuggets ça n'en fait et les personnes
mais ça bien la sienne ne prévient les
nuggets le dos de patrick le poulet non
non ça vient d'abord des patates
en lourd et chérie c'est l'équipe en
plus qui a dit fabriquer bernard montiel
aujourd'hui voilà moi alors je sais pas
si on s'en souvient sa date de la star
academy pas cheap qui composent pour
luan la pause j'aime regarder mais c est
pas çi ah ouais mais ouais ouais mais
c'est vrai patxi patxi pas qu'on me le
dire merci à mme giraldi mais il est
resté avec lui françois hollande dîner
avec lui il est très sympathique
alors vous sylvia bongo la première dame
du gabon
non s'ils sont saisis si j'abandonnais
dit souvent ouais euh
sylvia bongo alors ils s'entraînent la
même façon mais c'est vrai c'est la
femme d'ali bongo
bah oui on se doutait bah oui donc c'est
sylvia bongo avait sonné les mêmes on
dirait ma soeur non c'est pas vrai buzz
j'ai hâte de la voir fac centrale a
cherché à mon avis est en train de faire
des recherches
ah oui d'accord vous berne a voté oui
oui oui mais grave
à gauche c'est toi ça on est les mêmes
mais c'est incroyable la vérité est là
franchement c'est fou incroyable lcl est
très jolie ah ouais bravo vous alors moi
on m'a toujours dit brad pitt
[Rires]
[Musique]
dans un match deux minutes oui en terme
d'humour t'avais pas réparti les rôles
il est insupportable et l'anarchie alors
film d'acteurs qui était l'homme
arkin regard des lavallois regret c'est
un acteur qui a été nommé trois fois
pour le l'oscar du meilleur acteur
regardez alors mieux que rien ça doit
qu'ils ont galéré pour trouver une photo
on dirait selon moi il y en a marre un
peu non mais arrêtez et arrêter de faire
croire à tout le monde qu'ils sont mieux
que les photos on va les arrêter ils
préfèrent s'en voit ilan arkin que je
suis moche mais pas du tout essayé de le
gouvernement semble pas du tout peur à
moi votre barque bamboo de brad pitt
mais bon quand même gentil nous a dit
brees fred offre était et je sais plus
quoi en faire quoi pour repérer des
faits nous donne issue la note il nous a
dit je sympathisais le public a eu
raison le reste serait à l'avoir coaché
par toyer et raymond 16e avant de passer
ce sens unique on ressemble à personne
notamment moi bah vous allez voir vous
allez est unique tout seul alors vous
quelqu'un de vivant s'il vous plaît et
bah alors moi le retrouve pas partout
mais on m'a dit géraldine chaplin
l'acide
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'arrête là je vous combien elle est
très jolie mais vous êtes mieux je
réussis que ce soit en étant le docteur
jivago
c'est super tu es génial c'est super tu
es ce que fait une super émission du
fait de supers année alors il fait son
arrivée dans l'île
[Applaudissements]
les verserait qui est là il va me dire
matt pokora ses bons amis
en plus moi vraiment au début j'ai dit
que les bateaux quand tu ne ressembles
grave moi ça dézingue ça n'est pas de
l'année moi on m'a dit au début au fait
l'élu escudero au moniteur de plâtre
c'est ça on peut arrêter celui d'abord
c'était celui d'abord c'est qu'ils ont
fait c'est qu'il n'est pas tout cas que
aulas sur l'accueil des beaux gosses
c'est fou ça c'est un truc de cinq
assassinats et moi mon ipad je suis le
sosie d'un mec alors vous allez voir il
s'appelle russell poutine c'est un
célèbre producteur de musique indien les
très très riches sur vous le dites
coiffer ce cas qu'est ce qu'une annonce
avoir gardé zèle c'est le même si c'est
le même avec tous ces mieux il est mieux
oui sachez que lui il est peut-être bon
choix mais il est très très longue
jusqu'aux os
j'en ai marre c'est bon allez